We're here in Leiden  in the Netherlands.
Everything that you see around me was once completely submerged in water.
The only reason why the Netherlands is still dry today
is because a series of dikes have been constructed around the country.
Now even with these dikes, we still need to constantly move water from low to high
or as we learn to say by the end of this unit, we need to do work on the water
to move at some place of low potential energy to places of high potential energy.
Today, the dikes that surround the Netherlands help to keep its 17 million inhabitants safe
but without human intervention, all the areas that you see in blue would be submerge.
Since so much of the country is actually below sea level.
Of course this setup isn't perfect, water constantly must be transported up and away from land.
One tool, the Archimedes' screw uses power
from the Dutch windmills to transport this water and keep the Netherlands dry.
We learned about forces in the last unit but thinking in terms of forces may not be enough
to understand this complex problem.